so this is actually a new project but up
until now I just go up to 30 people
every day and ask them the same question
okay but today I'm doing even a little
bit different instead of leading the
conversation with the question I'm just
going to tell you that I either have 100
subscribers or a million subscribers but
I'm giving you the stage for up to five
minutes to talk about whatever you want
anything
[Applause]
I'd like right now for five minutes up
to five minutes okay okay so something
has been on my mind recently is
depression and the fact that it looks
different and everybody and the fact
that no matter how happy you might seem
to other people like you could be really
really [ __ ] up
I've seen it so many times to my friends
and even myself
and I've had a friend recently passed
away
happy and laughing one day
but things like it's important to just
like check in with your
daily or weekly or whatever you feel
like you need
to say hey like how are you just get to
the like part of everything
[Music]
like permanent miss or how things aren't
permanent
you would explain that one okay well
like nothing in life is like really
permanent I guess like
like everything that's supposed to like
mean that it's like forever like it is
it actually forever they I don't know
everything can change like nothing is
like guaranteed in life I guess like
that's what I've been thinking about
so what'd you think about that lately my
parents
getting like bowl like they've been
separated for like two weeks now
yeah I don't know I just been like
thinking about that and how like I don't
know like things are just like supposed
to like work out and they don't
Mulder you 16 just like people I've been
talking to like my co-workers are older
than me and like they told me like all
their problems and then like I look at
my life and I'm like I do not have these
problems but like I know I will [ __ ] and
like it's scary but I guess it's like
life so okay well I will talk about
something that's very dear to my heart
and that is I have two grandchildren
and one is just turned 3 and she's a
little miracle baby they didn't think
that she was gonna survive didn't think
she was even going to be born and now
she's three years old and she's very
very strong
you knew feminine divine presence on the
planet and it's a very awesome
generation that's been more
and she now has a little brother who's a
month two months old and he is very
sweet and kind and beautiful and white
light and he's here to be her protector
because she has several palsy and
[Music]
even though she's very strong and
teaching us all she's going to need
a very strong
spend the rest of her life with and very
honored
to watch this little beautiful girl grow
up I'm consistently thinking about you
know how I'm gonna be making it in this
world I'm gonna I'm in a group I play in
a band I play bass
I do backup vocals and it's been a
beautiful journey for years been in the
group and that's just one job that I
won't quit it keeps me going
although a lot of the times it's peanuts
and pocket-lint when it comes to get
paid you know I cannot make it much but
you're getting a lot of spiritual rock
and roll that just doesn't come from you
know your average day to day job but
aside from keeping myself together when
it comes to financial income that's you
know a little bit of a trick it's kind
of tricky these days but I always had
its friend that told me not to let my
income determine my outcome so I think
I'm gonna run with that philosophy for
now I love the city I love this people
friends family good support system and I
have a beautiful girlfriend who I love
very much
and I just want to put that out there
and she supports everything that I do as
well in the group and with my family
friends but um god it's hard to pinpoint
what I have on my mind just there's
never just one thing on my mind it's it
changes from day to day but that's part
of the beauty of life right
the ever-evolving
[Music]
mind you know
but uh aside from that you know it's all
it's all positive from here got a work
hard for that stay and if you're in
school stay in school all your kids out
there you know life is tough without it
but um I wouldn't recommend the route
taken either you know rock and roll
crazy you know grungy bars but it works
for me it's working for me right now and
I'm gonna keep going with that without
it also if he took the group in the band
away and probably my girlfriend and a
few other things I would I would feel
bad you know life would just be
miserable but with them I love it life
is beautiful
and I advise everyone to just love each
other love love each other you know if
you haven't talked to your sister your
brother your father your cousin or
whatever you know for some little stupid
reason you know really suck it up and
just be an adult and call them or go
with them you know have a beer talk have
some lunch do it you know get out there
life is too short and
who knows these days with the way things
are going on in the world you never know
how any of our plans are gonna come
through you know it's kind of crazy so
live in the moment be here now and yeah
love each other that's my message thanks
for watching another episode if you
haven't already it would mean a lot if
you subscribe to my channel like this
video share it a couple episodes with
friends it helps support my project
thank you
[Music]